ok
seuls
trois jours pour apprendre les
techniques de défense c'était au
programme d'un stage organisé au dojo de
la police municipale du chesnay
rocancourt la trentaine de participants
présents étaient issus de la police
municipale nationale ou encore de la
gendarmerie cette formation sert à
former des instructeurs à la
manipulation du bâton de défense
tactique donc lui bâton télescopique ou
menottes
menottes qu'on a sur le terrain acier
mais aussi des systèmes soft qu'on
appelle laiterie fold s'est laissé
reflèxe un accent particulier a été mis
sur l'utilisation de la matraque
télescopique cette arme intermédiaire de
catégorie d est particulièrement utilisé
par les services de police vous êtes
confrontés souvent à déplier votre bâton
et à vous retrouver à en faire usage ou
plutôt en dissuasif sur beaucoup de
situations sur du regroupement sur de
l'agression parfois sur de la défense de
soi la défense d'autrui une partie
théorique rappeler aux stagiaires les
règles d'usagé de la force de la
légitime défense ou du flagrant délit la
pratique permettait aux participants de
se confronter à la réalité du terrain
plusieurs plateaux un plateau
ou le l'instructeur va montrer le
mouvement en fait puis après ligne donc
une mise en situation en opposition
statique donc avec du matériel dont
l'appel les training bague les
stagiaires étaient aussi mis en
mouvement pour augmenter l'effet de
surprise à face avec les soeurs ta
théorie - tu sais quoi c'est un atelier
de restitution en fait c'est pour se
rapprocher au plus près de la réalité
ils ont travaillé jusqu'à maintenant sur
des bagues ce soit en mouvement statique
et là en fait on va faire attaquer sur
une personne donc quand vous voyez je
suis je suis protégé par une armure les
leurs et demain nous là on sent
absolument rien j'ai apprécié la
progressivité
pédagogie tout au cours du stage
puisqu'on art d'abord commencer par
revoir les fondamentaux la théorie et
ensuite on s'est approprié les gestes
techniques ou pour certains pour
beaucoup les a tous révisé mais surtout
on a pu aller travailler
suffisamment longtemps pour pouvoir
voilà les acquérir un petit peu plus
cette formation était offerte par
l'équipementier à spa tous les
participants sélectionnés les stagiaires
sont repartis chacun avec l'équivalent
de 500 euros de matériel à utiliser dans
le cadre de leurs fonctions